foreign
you from Lagos Nigeria
one of the largest cities in Africa
by 2050 Lagos will outgrow many of the
largest cities in the world including
New York and Mexico City and will be
home to over 32 million people
by that same date Nigeria will be home
to more people than the United States
but there is a problem Lagos and other
African mega cities
suffer or plagued by limited road
infrastructure
pollution
congestion and poor safety conditions
this makes it very difficult for people
to get to work especially in low-income
communities
where poverty infrastructure gaps
are pervasive
enter the African motorcycle taxi driver
on two and three wheels they reach
through the congested streets of Africa
getting people on Goods to where they
need to be
unfortunately these drivers are excluded
from the formal economy
unable to afford to buy clean efficient
vehicles they are left to rent old gas
engines from exploitative loan sharks
because of this tough situation that
these drivers endure
they are often left to fend for
themselves
part of body also endure and software is
high costs of operations from this
exploitative loan sharks
and also these drivers pollute the
environment
if nothing is done
pollution from two and three wheeled
vehicles in Africa will hit 1.7 gigatons
of emissions every year according to our
estimates
this is equivalent to pollution from 2
million Boeing 737 airplanes every
single year
I left my engineering job in 2013 to go
to MIT where I met my co-founder chinedu
azada a fellow engineer with similar
dreams
we bonded about the realization that
Africa was being left behind in the
global transition to clean Mobility
inspired by the work of other innovators
around the world
we chose to embark on a journey to
create a three-part solution
which provides motorcycle taxi drivers
in Africa access to electric vehicles
battery swaps and maintenance
and also emergency assistance
here is how it works drivers sign up on
the platform
and instantly they get access to an
electric motorcycle
and a full battery swap
so therefore they're able to save up and
earn money to buy those vehicles
in addition we also help lower their
risks by providing them
access to Emergency Response health
insurance and maintenance plans
this represents an integrated approach
to the design
manufacturing financing and operations
of our Electric Mobility platform
targeted at highly vulnerable informal
and unbanked people groups
the revenue from the drivers covers the
cost of the electric Fleet and the
batteries
while the cost of r d and Technology
is covered by our partners including
foundations non-profits and investors
meets babagiro one of our drivers
before signing up on our platform he was
a small holder farmer earning three
dollars a day in the government
community in Southwestern Nigeria
tragedy struck When Baba meru lost his
first son
without help he struggled to transport
from produce
and therefore could not make ends meet
after signing up on our platform he
immediately got access to our electric
motorcycle plus a fully charged battery
on a daily basis
this enabled him to be able to transport
people in his community
make a little bit more money and also
meet his obligations including sending
his younger son to school
our platform enabled him to increase his
net income on a daily basis from three
dollars to six dollars
to date our Platformers serve the
network of over 15 000 drivers and our
data shows that the average driver has
about five dependents meaning that our
work has likely impacted over 75 000
livelihoods
by 2025 our goal is to provide the
Electric Mobility solutions to over 150
000 drivers
and if this idea really takes off
Electric Mobility innovators and climate
entrepreneurs in Africa could jointly
impact over 10 million motorcycle taxi
drivers
by doing this
we would be helping to move the world's
youngest and fastest growing continent
towards a more sustainable
and a prosperous future and we will be
creating jobs and reducing emissions
thank you very much
[Applause]